there are few single season shows out
there in the verse that have quite the
same cult following as Firefly but will
the space Western ever get the Revival
it deserves well we hate to damage your
calm but the chances don't exactly look
good the cancellation of firefly was
tragic when Fox began airing episodes of
what was Jos weeden's latest series they
did so completely out of order how you
do that with only 14 episodes at your
disposal seems beyond comprehension and
and instead of kicking off Firefly with
the very necessary pilot episode titled
Serenity Fox started with the second
episode called the train job
additionally objects in Space the last
produced episode of Firefly originally
intended as a season 1 finale was aired
just before the pilot and three episodes
never aired during the original Fox run
at all instead premiering in the United
Kingdom the following summer eventually
the Science Channel aired all 14
episodes in order though though Firefly
had been off the air for nearly a decade
by then so what took Firefly down though
the show was mostly well received by
critics High Praise sadly wasn't enough
to keep the serenity afloat aside from
outof Order episodes and Fox's
apparently unrealistic expectations the
real reason Firefly was canceled was low
ratings so rather than continue to try
and build a bigger audience over time
box asked the show before it even got
off the ground airing on Friday nights a
time slot some times referred to as the
Friday night death slot didn't help
either which set the series up to fail
that along with poor marketing that
failed to capture the rebel Spirit of
the show contributed harshly to the
untimely Fade to Black of
firefly no power in the verse can stop
me Firefly fans dubbed brown coats after
the band of rebels that some of the main
characters once belong to are unlike any
other it's because of their love for the
series and its characters that the
franchise has been able to continue in
any capacity for over 20 years after it
failed on Fox many viewers flocked to
DVD racks and online Market places to
express their continued interest in the
show miraculously Firefly DVD pre-sales
sold out on Amazon within 24 hours fans
continued to campaign for Fox to bring
Firefly back for another season sending
in letters emails and petitions to get
their favorite show back on the air
while Fox didn't budge others noticed
their efforts
recognizing the fans dedication to the
story Universal Pictures acquired the
film rights and green lit a feature set
to bring back the Firefly cast and crew
citing the show's impressive DVD sales
as enough potential to build something
bigger in 2006 a documentary about fan
involvement in Firefly and continuing
the story called done the impossible the
fan tale of firefly and serenity was
released as a love letter of sorts to
the show and its audience Adam Baldwin
who played Jane cob one of the serenity
's resident mercenaries narrated the
film while juel State who played
Serenity engineer Kaylee fry provided
some voiceover work ever since Firefly
fans have continued to show up and
support their show constantly hoping to
fund or inspire a Revival of some sort
when shows are canceled usually that's
it occasionally fans are able to save
shows for a time or they're revived
later on down the road but following
those impressive DVD sales and momentous
fan outcry Firefly returned once again
to the screen the big one this time in
2005 just a few years after Fox's
untimely cancellation Universal Pictures
released the Sci-Fi Action feature
Serenity a continuation film set to
conclude the series mythology and
satisfy those outspoken fans who hoped
for more though Jos Weeden originally
planned a multi-season series Serenity
allowed Weeden and his cast to revisit
the verse yet again even if for a final
time the Epic space Western genre mashup
up of the series translated masterfully
to the big screen not only are the
visuals a massive upgrade from the
television show but the increased budget
of a feature film allowed Weeden to tell
a bigger and more mythology heavy story
than could have been told on the small
screen well at least not at the time
though it was released about 2 years
after the series ended the events of
Serenity pick up only 2 months after the
impromptu series finale of firefly
continuing the alliance's pursuit of
River Tam played by summer glow and the
rest of the crew after DVD sales for
Firefly skyrocketed it seemed like a
good idea to continue the short-lived
series as a feature film for many there
was even hope for a continuing Serenity
franchise with multiple cinematic
installments rumors circulated about a
potential sequel but nothing ever came
of it after hoping DVD sales for the
feature may do for the film what they
did for the television series a Serenity
sequel faded out of Universal's preview
on the since decommissioned Jos themed
Weeden esque website weed didn't told
fans there's no sequel no secret project
regarding Serenity or some such I'm not
even sure how anyone thought there was
talk there with that the hopes of many
were dashed but in 2015 Weeden was
singing a slightly different tune when
talking with Empire about the potential
future of the franchise he went on to
remark that although he didn't foresee a
theatrical sequel he still hoped for a
television Revival of firefly one day
reiterating his love for the IP he told
the outlet as long as I was able to
service the characters with integrity
and had enough money so that I wasn't
hampered then I would love to return
Serenity to TV there could be a series
there could be a minseries there could
be all sorts of things I'm not ruling
anything out although a sequel to
Serenity wasn't likely to happen some
sort of liveaction continuation of
firefly seemed possible somewhere down
the
line could be bumpy always is the
continued questions of how one can or
should divorce the Creator from the
creation are tough to to answer for some
separating the art from the artist
especially in a television context in
which hundreds of artists are involved
is relatively easy for others it's
nearly impossible wherever you fall on
that Spectrum there's no denying that
the more recent controversies
surrounding Jos Weeden made it
increasingly difficult for Firefly to
return ever since vulture published a
2022 article that produced several
allegations from cast and crew members
of Buffy the Vampire Slayer Angel
dollhouse and Justice League the Firefly
creator has been keeping a much lower
profile while Weeden wasn't the only
filmmaker associated with firefly he is
the creator of the franchise and
responsible for writing several episodes
as well as the film which he also
directed but some are still willing to
work with Weeden again in the future in
an interview on the inside of you
podcast Nathan fillian noted that it
would be heartbreaking if Firefly
continued without its creator regarding
the previously mentioned allegations
billian said that was not my experience
with that man I would work with Jos
again in a second wherever the truth
about Weeden lies he has nothing coming
down the Hollywood pipeline making the
chances of any more unscreen Firefly
Adventures Slimmer but despite weeden's
troubles many of the cast members want
to continue on depending on who you ask
you may get different answers regarding
the likelihood of more Firefly both
Nathan fillian and Alan tudk who played
pilot Hoban was wasburn have starkly
different ideas on a Revival according
to Filan who has said his time on
Firefly was the best job he ever had
there's no real need for any more
adventures in a 2015 interview with
Esquire he admitted we were able to have
a nice kind of final goodbye we had
closure which is more than a lot of
people with canceled shows can say
nevertheless in his 2022 interview with
Michael rosenbom fillian revealed that
he' jump at the chance to play M
Reynolds once more on the flip side Alan
tudk adamantly wants a firefly reboot
but with a Twist tudk told Esquire that
quote it's going to take a little time
saying that he likes the idea of it in
another 10 years or so he believes that
Clint Eastwood's Western epic Unforgiven
is the best model to follow just with
dillian's character at the center so you
going to ride shotgun with me help me
fly that's the plan conversely actress
Summer glow commented that she was torn
on a Revival since Firefly is an
Underdog Story at heart she told the
convention junkies I think that part of
the magic about Firefly is that it
didn't last and that all of the fans are
the ones keeping it alive though glow
said she wouldn't be able to stay away
from a reboot she isn't sure if the
magic could be
recaptured you've lost her lad be
gracious of course not every Firefly
star actively wants to come back for a
full-on Revival series marinaa bararan
who played Serenity tenant and high
society sex worker inara sah has
expressed that she's not overly
interested in returning to play the
character again in the future on a 2023
episode of inside of view she told
Michael Rosa bomb I like laying some
things to rest we should do a reunion or
we should do like a podcast or talk or
like a one-off like friends did that'd
be fun right I don't really need to
resuscitate the show for me bearan was
speaking of friends the reunion in which
the original cast reunited on the
original set to reminisce on their time
with the series while many had hoped for
a narrative continuation of friends the
cast reunion special is as close as
we're likely to get with that in mind a
firefly reunion special might be the
most practical way to bring bring the
Beloved cast back together in the late
2010s Fox thought about pursuing a
firefly Revival it turns out Fox Exact
Michael Thorne is a big fan of the
series and like many other fans wants a
Revival during that time Fox was
Reviving previous hits such as 24 and
the ax files for limited runs and the
network reportedly looked at bringing
back the space Western 2 Thorne told the
rap in 2020 just after Disney purchased
20th Century Fox it had come up before
but we had the Orville on the air and it
didn't make sense for us to have as a
broadcast network who is very targeted
to have two space franchises on our air
of course the Orval soon moved to Hulu
which opened the door for a firefly
return but Fox doesn't seem to have
pursued it any further while dubiously
sourced clickbaity rumors of an in
development pg-rated Firefly reboot for
Disney plus with a new cast and no
involvement from Jos Weeden elicited an
all two predictable fan outrage no new
information rumored or otherwise has
emerged regarding the matter since
roughly 2021 considering that Disney
plus already has a popular space western
series you might have heard of called
the Mandalorian the mouse doesn't seem
to have an immediate demand for more
Firefly you're going to make do with
what you got tying into the release of
Serenity Darkhorse Comics published a
many series titled Serenity those Left
Behind meant to fill in the gaps between
the series and the feature film this
eventually led to two more limited comic
series before catching up with the
film's timeline leaves on the wind was
released in 2014 and was was followed by
no power in the verse in 2016 officially
ending darkhorse's comic book tenure
with the franchise since Jos Weeden and
Company penned Dark Horses Serenity
Tales they're considered more or less
Canon filling in gaps from the show's
run additionally an ongoing series of
firefly novels have been published by
Titan books with each story interweaving
between the show's 14 episodes then in
2018 boom Studios acquired the comic
book rights and began releasing stories
in the verse with their Firefly comic
book Rebrand with input from Jos Weeden
writer Greg pck crafted new adventures
for the serenity crew soon a sequel
series titled allnew Firefly was
launched ending in December 22 with a
One-Shot titled Big Damn finale while
it's unclear if we'll ever get a proper
Firefly Revival the comics are the
truest continuation of the short-lived
space Western while we hope that some
other project like a movie or an audio
drama could be produced somewhere down
the line One Thing Remains Ever Clear
Firefly may be gone but no one can take
the sky
[Music]
away